oriented here so
this is a very experimental talk i
have circulated this paper the paper is
completely written but the last time i
presented this was at the university of
arizona to their philosophy department
right before covid to jerry gauss's
group and he unfortunately has passed
away in the meantime and now here i am
postcoded for the first time back
hoping to make some progress with this
paper
so um just to give you an overview of
the whole
synthesis of the argument so
at the background of this is thinking
about what did we mean by a kind of
sovereignty that has individual autonomy
and some kind of legitimate collective
sovereignty to think about how that
moves into
a world in which as we know when
president trump was president when biden
as president these individuals can
literally destroy the world and that
this time window for making that
decision is so compressed we don't even
really know how much it's going to be
machine assisted
systems
versus actual human decision making
then i'm going to be introducing you to
integrated information theory i hope
that there might be somebody who knows
something about that from a technical
perspective and not just from a
theoretical philosophical perspective
applying it to nuclear command and
control asking what kinds of
intelligence systems do we have now with
this hybrid
computerized and human intelligence
massive systems and then to think about
the trajectory of the materiality of
these nuclear weapons systems of their
command and control in terms of what
kind of agency
are we imagining and materializing to
have those kinds of sovereign properties
so i really was appreciative of helen's
talk yesterday to put on the board the
idea of the kantian subject which is
under so much western political theory
that you have autonomous individuals and
somehow through
correct institutions say constitutional
rule of law those individuals can come
together and make collective decisions
in a legitimate way
so we have and and that's the basis of
where we are under western institutions
but that increasingly through the cold
war i really um we bringing up that
whole idea of the consumer sovereignty
we increasingly question that we can
move from individual liberal autonomous
subjects to some kind of collective will
formation so this consumer sovereignty
is basically the residue of what remains
at least within the rational actor
paradigm and then increasingly even
looking at um the
the fate of the habermasian deliberative
model in europe it's really collapsed
more to the neoliberal turn that you
could see in macron's and uh cameron's
approach to politics and underlying the
eu's rule of law
so how do we maintain legitimate
collective authority over weapons of
mass destruction with this really tight
15-minute decision window if there was
um some kind of a crisis and we we know
i can't go into the american
u.s policy in fact i'll just leave that
if there's any questions about the
different capabilities and
theoretical
justification of that of course we all
know that this is more recent that
there's huge
increases in terms of the amount of
money that's spent on defense and this
there's a revolution underway in terms
of nuclear command and control and the
whole
next generation of nuclear weapons
systems is currently underway
i have been working
in collaboration with the cambridge
university center for existential risk
and have with my co-author shahara bean
we've actually looked at best practices
in terms of
artificial intelligence systems and how
they could and probably should not be
integrated into nuclear commanding
controls have actually done work in that
community
to focus on the question i'm going to
consider today
it is how do we now think about
justifying the kind of collective
sovereignty that it would take to make
these life and death decisions which are
imminently hanging above us at every
single moment how do we bounce that
against the materiality and the actual
functioning of the nuclear command and
control system and this is a book from
2016 i think that is also looking at
this question
so to look at what is nuclear command
and control well it's actually all of
these different attributes command
control communications computers
intelligence surveillance and
reconnaissance it's sometimes called
nc4isr
to look at the whole
lot the complex
of technological systems that are there
that are integrated with humans and also
if you're reading in this literature
then this was from daniel vollmar's
thesis this um
90 billion dollar price tag that the
amount spent on command and control
during the whole cold war was 90 the
amount spent on just the material
production of the weapons and all of
that research so command and control
without that you don't have any kind of
projection of sovereignty or any ability
to wield these weapons and that's a
dimension that's
not often thought of and of course this
would challenge the premise of
democratic sovereignty and democratic
governance
because of the tight time windows and
that the amount of uncertainty that
could be involved in making a call on
whether there's some kind of imminent
attack so now the next part of my talk
is to introduce you really quickly to
integrated information theory i don't
know if anybody in the room is even
familiar with it
i haven't to really test this paper and
to submit it for publication i'm going
to have to embed it through some expert
in integrated information theory the
problem is that it's mostly applied to
the brain and the mind and it's a new
theory of what it means to be
intelligent and even conscious so it's a
theory of the mind as a computational
information processor but it's
formulated in mathematical theorems and
it is basically a physicalist outlook
on in terms of consciousness that it
just comes down to the physical
substrate of the brain as an
informational processing unit
that then gives rise to this this
subtract this this
experience of consciousness
so i'm working in the analytic tradition
with this paper in terms of christian
lists and eric schwitzgable and they
together have started to think about
well our groups of agents in some
form
or way
emergent in terms of having some kind of
supervening quality that can come about
through collective decision making so
they're they've been debating
theoretically over the last decade our
group's reducible to individuals and
switchgable he basically just gave kind
of a um
an absurd argument showing that if you
went down the certain road of theorizing
then you would conclude that the u.s
itself
is irreducible
to the individuals that comprise it
christian list came back and he actually
applies integrated information theory
and he applies it beyond the level of an
individual to thinking about how could
we apply to a group of individuals so
that there are many brains working in
conjunction to reach decisions so that's
giving you a background and this
switch cable gives this remarkable
argument that the us should be
considered to be conscience list
responds and he uses guilo tinoni's
integrated information theorists which
i'll
give you
a little bit more detail on here is for
example he's a very um popular
well-known author despite the fact he's
obviously an academic and if you google
his name he's massively cited he claims
that integrated information theory
addresses the hard problem of
consciousness how neural mechanisms give
rise to consciousness
he says iit provides a mathematical
framework for evaluating the quality and
quantity of consciousness how does this
work
that we think about consciousness as
information flows across the brain and
that
how this processing works is the
substrate for phenomenal consciousness
and that ultimately the higher degree of
integrated information processing the
higher the degree of consciousness and
that this consciousness would not be
reducible to constitutive parts so the
goal is to measure systems level of
integration
integrated information this value of phi
measures the irreducibility of a cause
effect repertoire with respect to
partitions obtained by combining the
irreducibility of its constituent cause
and effect repertoires map onto the same
partitions
so that you measure this is measured in
bits denotes the size of the conscious
repertoire associated with any network
of causally interacting parts and i'm
just showing that this is stated in
terms of
mathematical text and actually this is
um scott erinson has has um
written on
on this material and he's um i mean
everything he writes is brilliant but
i've definitely integrated what he said
in terms of my analysis of i'm not an
advocate of iit it's more looking at
what would be the implications if we
start thinking about iit and also
thinking that iit is the best way to try
to analyze nuclear command and control
in terms of its vulnerabilities to
introducing entropy to some part of the
system so here's basically how this
works and i have to go through it really
quickly but if this is the human brain
then it would be
partitioning it in half and saying well
if we destroy or randomize the input
from half of the brain can the rest of
the brain function but then you don't
just do that once you do it every single
different partition you find the
partition where there would be the least
amount of randomization from
if you introduce entropy from the input
on the
the um a side could the b side continue
and the the partition with the least
impact would be your level
of
integrated information processing in
your degree of consciousness
so according to
iit claims that human consciousness has
a high capacity for integrated
information and he thinks this does
reflect consciousness
so christianity applies this to a group
and just to go all the way through his
paper really quickly he concludes that
iit theory will not give you that a
group agent has any kind of emergent
decomposable
consciousness
and
i am adding to this debate with my paper
applying it to nuclear command and
control and using so this is a
concluding sentence from list where he
says an important difference
in ultimate moral significance between
individuals and groups lies precisely in
their difference with respect to
consciousness so list is basically
conceding that if a group or some hybrid
agent in my case
could be said to have a high degree of
this this fee then in that case then
that could be said to have this high
degree of consciousness and i'm
cautioning that we go down this road of
using integrated information theory in
this way because i think that with
nuclear command and control it actually
there may be a very high level of
integration but that the materiality of
that system then would end up treating
it as though it has some kind of morally
significant personhood with all of those
attributes of self-defense and
justifying what that system decides to
do
and um
looking at there's a lot of
literature now looking at multi-agent
systems that include artificial
intelligences with human human systems
and i think
this nc4isr is probably
maybe the biggest
or the
the elephant in the room in terms of
well what would be that kind of system
that you could start applying this type
of iit metric to now this is all
speculative and if anybody here wanted
to challenge this
i haven't submitted this paper to
publication yet because i'd like to get
a better sense of whether you could in
fact argue that no matter how much you
partition the core element of nuclear
command and control there's no way that
it could be decomposable it could be
that you have two parallel systems but
that's even hard to imagine but that
basically every aspect of this nuclear
command and control system is vital to
maintaining and projecting that kind of
sovereignty and it's in the massive
cause effect
repertoire because if you integrate some
kind of segment that's been randomized
then you make a fallacious decision then
the cause effects repertoire would be
calamitous for the whole world so this
is considering all the different
partitions just jumping to my hypothesis
that in the end if you have all the
partitions and you would have you could
break it down in various ways but that
in the end you
there's no way you could decompose this
and still have your nuclear command and
control system that's my hypothesis and
so far in all the different audiences
i've given nobody's actually challenged
that in a way that
i've had to respond but i'm open to that
so if i compare what list was doing with
just human groups and what i've been
doing with this hybrid group of the
machines
in nuclear combat and control in the
humans that this is not a decomposable
system that if you're randomizing the
cortex function of this nuclear command
and control that that would be a
sovereignty loss you wouldn't be able to
project power through these weapons and
that this human you you can you need the
machines to have this nuclear security
complex and arguably so far at least in
the united states people said you need
to have humans in the loop at all levels
of decision making
and there's questions about to what
extent machine assisting
um assist systems should be integrated
into the decision process this is just a
snapshot that if you're looking at
warfare in general it's called
well there's informational warfare
this is from something called metric
network centric warfare and this author
is basically arguing that even in small
units of men and machines that are
operating autonomously in the field that
you go from information to shared
awareness self-synchronization and that
there is emergent properties of behavior
that are coming out of these military
units that are way smaller than nuclear
command and control
so just to come to my conclusion
that you could calculate
in some conceptual way
that this five value of this nc for isr
and that the system requires global
situational awareness
and that you now we require human
integration to the system we have
massive control of kinetic systems with
huge outcomes in the defense planners
themselves are massively worried about
randomization which is why all the money
is spent on nuclear command and control
so my tentative hypothesis is that
maintaining national sovereignty which
would be unified informed and directed
within c4 isr requires a level of
systems integration above and beyond
that of solely collective human agency
this may have a completely
a higher level of disintegrated
information processing than individuals
or classical governance and search
stable lists together open up the
possibility for finding some kind of
intelligence in these systems and then
ultimately
maybe
opening the door to
at least de facto treating these as
having some kind of
personhood moral personhood which we
used to think of like for hobbes the
nation state has some kind of corporate
personhood that has all those attributes
of autonomy making decisions and
self-defense for example
so i think this is my concluding slide
i said that if we open the
permissibility of using iit to identify
consciousness
then that this nuclear command and
control might be very susceptible to
that analysis so that nuclear command
and control may be thought of as this
new leviathan of these emergent
statehood from these hybrid human
computational systems and that this of
course would not have the old-fashioned
attributes of individual autonomy and
collective ethical accountability
and thank you that's my talk and i think
i just got through it in time
[Applause]
thank you so much to both of you for
not just
wonderful talks but for me as a
moderator coming in i didn't even have
to be a time bully that's great um yeah
so lee sonia i'll have you both come on
up here i'll pull the chairs out for you
and then we can open it up for uh
yeah jake you want to come up to we have
a chair for you
um and i will um start feel no i can
stand um i'll start
fielding questions um and i following
helen's pattern if everyone could um i
have first helen um introduce yourself
um quickly before you ask your question
um i'll hand this mic off to you guys to
begin answering but um if everyone could
just keep their hands up so
i think i have it
this one but let me just okay here i'm
going to get you started and then people
hold their hands up
hi um my name is george i'm a grad
student here at berkeley and
my question is specifically about the
nuclear command control
is it advisable to sort of like
overthink this and specifically
introduce
automated decision making and even
automated information processing
especially you know in conjunction with
like launch on warning or should we just
try to move the whole world towards
survivable second strike and to have
that be like
a political decision as opposed to you
know introducing more sort of like
information processing and you know
automation and is that just like a
rabbit hole we shouldn't be going down
thanks that's an easy question yes
absolutely and that's what most of my
work is dedicated to but but if you're
in that and if you're in the department
of defense then you are going to be
thinking about your informational
security of these systems and that's why
the nuclear command and control gets
all of this weapons and the money and
development but yes i totally agree with
what you're seeing
i'd like to just ask both
papers a quick question
um for lee and jake
am i understanding correctly so the
justific the moral justification for the
free market as a decision procedure
for policy is to say you know if we let
the market decide
um we assume rational actors
everything's going to work out well for
society like the good stuff will be
produced and it will be bought blah blah
blah but now you're showing that there's
this weird
uh two-faced consumer so i i'd be
curious to understand if that's
correct concern and then a quick
question i don't know how quick but to
sonia
um
in my own reading around autonomy i
actually i'm more influenced by a
more recent conception
of
an autonomous individual not the liberal
autonomous individual but rather
the autonomy that develops as
individuals or members of society so
it's fully integrated into social
being and
therefore when you present this idea of
groups
groups
decomposable into individuals i just
don't even understand that idea
because individuals already are
group created
entities and so
um
and so now reflecting on the way you're
thinking of your
hybrid
these hybrid what you're calling hybrid
agents
i also
am wondering
you know what would it mean to actually
decompose
into
the different entities when
each of the parts of it is built with a
conception of
its
projected interaction
with the other parts of it
so
yeah i mean i have the same
question uh
about
both of these concepts just curious
i'll say something quick and then give
it to jake so two things i would say
about about that uh two points um first
yes so there's like
the presumption of liberal autonomous
subjects making rational decisions in a
marketplace that doesn't align with the
platform environment where you have
algorithmic modes of rational
discrimination trying to orchestrate
behavior in a decidedly like non-market
formulation so you have the presumption
of markets
legitimizing this arrangement that's
decidedly not a market formation in lots
of ways so yes on that point the other
thing i'd say is sort of to reverse your
first formulation of like we have
liberal actors so we need markets to
coordinate their behavior
in some way what we're showing is that
we have markets and so we need liberal
actors to justify their existence and so
um
yeah
i actually because i loved your paper
and i do think cause from
just jumping into sort of i don't know
if i'm defending you guys but totally
agreeing that in the sense of that
consumer sovereignty um and
that
we still do have that as a justification
of the markets and we still do think we
need to satisfy preferences and then the
behavioral economist i think he did a
great job explaining how from from their
perspectives we're not really rational
but that but those are our two paradigms
and so i think i thought you captured
really
well what i think is would be um the way
i would try to describe it but i'm not
doing the research so just to throw that
in
um so helen thank you for your question
i i
i think we should be moving to different
ways of thinking about how individual
autonomy would be construed in terms of
groups the analytic work i was following
was pettit and list
and they together have i don't know if
it's old-fashioned at this point but
they really stress that you have these
this rational actor type of agent that
has some kind of autonomy
i know i would disagree so i'd be really
interested to follow more well what
would be the alternative and then to go
down that like with the first question
to think well given the massive highway
of mainstream thinking that has
brought us to
still conceding the rational actor
in addition to the behavioral economist
deconstruction of it as as this you
can't get outside of that
and then also the materiality of the
nuclear command and control system which
is basically that's that's where so many
of our resources are going and trying to
think but how could we take that in a
different direction because i do think
that with nuclear command and control
and those weapons that until we can
undo that system we're all beholden to
it in some way and that all you know
we're putting resources into it there it
has significant existential risk and
it's locking us into some kind of view
even if we move from list and pettit to
conceding some iit version nuclear
command and control it's not the world i
would want to live in so i'd be curious
to explore what you're putting forward
as an alternative
um
just because you guys gave
such excellent responses i
uh
you know made me think a little bit more
about helen's question
um
and you know
this this question that motivates the
paper like how does the rational actor
sell the right to exploit their
irrationality can be can be kind of
framed in a few different ways and as
you know salome and lee and i have done
this work on mechanism design that sort
of also bounces off some of the work
that i keem birch has done
suggesting you know
these aren't these aren't markets and
like they're certainly not like
productive markets in the way that
that like allocative efficiency like
normatively connects onto because like
data is being moved around and
distributed um but what is data doing
it's it's kind of not this commodity
it's kind of just this flow that's used
to price attention in in different ways
and it's sort of something like really
weird and it doesn't look like uh
markets as we would understand them to
justify those accounts and then salome
went i remember when we were like
sitting next to each other and you were
like thinking about your um
relational theory of data governance
paper you you said to me that was like
you know there's this like kantian
privacy paradigm on one hand and then
there's like the american sort of
character
yeah the
caricature is lockheed or libertarian
privacy paradigm on the other hand and
there's something in the middle and i've
thought about that for
for like a long time
because it seems to me like
what's the real politic of what's
happened in the middle is this sort of
consumer protection paradigm
and the behavioral economics paradigm
with this sort of kantian personality on
one hand or the
you know libertarian
rationale on the other hand just
effectively being a gloss on what is now
global economic hegemony that sees data
in these particular ways
and
um and and requires that we think about
data markets
but these are markets so like
that we that we frame it in consumer
protection
makes it impossible for us to think
about as anything other than markets and
so like the response that i've been
thinking about is like well then how do
we what what do we even have the
language to pull
our relationship to platforms out of
this
market vocabulary like you know so the
question i'm asking like the title of
the essay would be like how do you
decommodify data right and uh like you
certainly can't do it through consumer
protection you know and you certainly
can't do it through these um
political rationales
uh that like starting in the you know
20s and consumer sovereignty and then
reiterate you know and i real we really
take from your work sonia like the the
relationship between um you know the
rational choice paradigms
post like during and post cold war and
their relationship to the fair
information practices that and the oecd
take up of all of that um i think that's
that's exactly where that all comes from
and uh so like yeah so i think we're
kind of stuck and like
you know
we love like this work on what's a
relational theory of data governance and
i've started thinking about like
well how like what's the first step of
of pulling it out of the market paradigm
and that's that's that's that's part of
what this is all about
obviously we could talk about this but
i'm going to start clumping questions
because there are so many so ben green
is going to ask this question and then
he's going to hand the mic to ben
um to ask his question
we got the ben round um i'm ben i'm a
postdoc at the university of michigan um
yeah thanks for this really great work
and i think it really
followed from where we ended the first
session with this idea of really adding
complexity and complicating the idea of
the human and i think you know
especially
uh lee your talk and your work with jake
sort of highlights this idea of the
human as something that can be
constructed in multiple different ways
in one paradigm we can say that you can
have these platforms that essentially
have two different notions of the human
that are both
beneficial to them in that domain
and i think sort of building off what
jake was saying at the end there sort of
how the different
language that we're using whether it's
markets or human and so on can actually
in some cases
make our efforts at reform and equity
more complicated rather than
easier because we're sort of not in the
right conceptual framework and
potentially this language can be wielded
by powerful actors to benefit their own
interests so
you know i'd be particularly curious uh
lee and jay sort of what you see
as some of the broader lessons of that
particular case study around these
different notions of the human as it
pertains to
sort of the broader frame of this
session but especially as the human has
become this sort of calling card for a
critical response to ai and
where that metaphor is is falling short
and is actually potentially
playing into the hands of the our
opponents so to speak in much the same
way that we've seen with terms like
ethics and fairness being wielded
similarly thanks
[Music]
hi um i'm ben laufer i'm a phd student
at cornell tech i work with helen um and
i think my question is pretty similar to
ben's
um
i guess
it's interesting how you slice the kind
of or how you set up this dichotomy and
it's for lee and jake um between
the idea of a of a rational actor and
and the kind of predictable
irrationalities and i wonder if like
there's a conceptualization or a way to
unify in terms of the strategy of some
of these platforms
and i think you've kind of spoken to
this a little bit when you've talked
about like behavioral
kind of like overarching behavioral
science ways of approaching
um
uh behave like user behavior but i think
kind of coming out of um various
research in various fields there's this
idea of like short and long term rewards
motivating people's behavior so like
describing why somebody would choose to
eat a donut instead of a salad might
be helpful in explaining what people's
behaviors are online and the idea that
[Music]
a lot of these like terms and service
agreements come up in a context where
they just want to get there they kind of
want a short-term reward and they might
act according to a short a shorter term
um set of
you know considerations so like i guess
more generally i would love to hear you
guys speak to
um how these notions of this self or the
individual both get operationalized by
platforms and whether there is any like
unity and
the strategic approach to
uh to kind of mine users for data
well i think jake should probably answer
this because he needs more time to talk
so just kind of to answer both questions
at once in some sense um
let me just like narrate the process of
this paper a little bit to you which i
think sort of gets to it which was that
i was recognizing this dichotomy right
the rational actor that's codified in
the privacy law and then the ear
particularly irrational thing and i was
like well this is like a weird
contradiction right how can these two
things exist at once and then jake came
in very brilliantly and said in fact
it's not so much they're contradictory
it's that they work together to
stabilize this particular mode of
accumulation and to justify these sort
of business models and allow them to
have legitimacy and
you know in the eyes of regulators in
the eyes of the public in the eyes of
customers these you need these different
constructions for this whole business to
make sense to be legal and to be
profitable
um and so
so yeah that's what yes
yeah and to to to that extent the
methodological
suggestion is that like
don't start with the human and then work
out what happens you play the game the
same way which is like the human remains
a variable
find the particular political
arrangement you want and then work back
to define what the human is because like
what we see in like
the legal thinking for instance you know
and you you pulled out this this history
in trademarks is that like particular
qualities of human
cognition capacity
like that
in that are inscribed in law have very
little connection to empirical reality
right instead what they do is privilege
one particular set of actors over others
uh
and that moves through the human so like
the human capacity to distinguish marx
to distinguish brands like if you say
that like uh humans are like really
really good at this you're kind of
privileging like a
a a a
like a group of producers who are sort
of newcomers and challenging
like incumbent actors but if you say
humans are really bad at distinguishing
marks and you're privileging the
incumbent actors in a particular market
um and and giving them a privileged
position and law like will ascribe
describe reasonableness
according to its
you know
particular preference for who who's
entitled to have that that benefit um it
has very little to do with actual human
capacity to to make those distinctions
and so and we're sort of saying the same
thing's going on here like you're going
to the x is a variable in a mark the
human is an x which is a variable in a
market formulation
um and and that's
that's what we see
okay i think we're going to take another
cluster of
comments from
peter and then
two questions one would be for uh jake
and lean and the other one for sonia
it seems uh jake and lee that what
you're suggesting is that the way that
we conceive the human
constrains or makes possible certain
kinds of critique of these
technological systems that we're now
embedded within whether it's this
attention economy the informational
capitalism you're talking about or
surveillance capitalism according to
zubal
so i'm wondering whether one of the
basic presuppositions seems to be
to continue to hear
that well maybe we're not liberal
individuals
but
i don't hear the language of us being
persons
that are relationally constituted
it seems to be that the presupposition
that's still operative is that we are in
some way ontologically individual
ontologically or individual basically
and we enter into relations with others
or with technological systems
contingently
and i wonder if we flip that and just
say
relations are constitutive
and everything else is an abstraction
from it so that what we're trying to do
is to figure out what's the best way to
disambiguate
the nature of the human in order to be
able to get the kind of critical
purchase that we want and whether or not
that's a way of thinking things through
that resonate with you guys
then for sonia one of the things about
iit
is that it's it's really a quantitative
measure
it's mathematical quantitative and it
has to do it's a measure of a system's
overall capacity for being able to ins
to influence causally its own future
states so that's what's built into the
iit model of consciousness
and that's all quantifiable but i wonder
whether
to complete your project of sort of
critique of these systems and how they
impact the world whether we somehow need
to introduce a notion of qualities of
consciousness
as opposed to simply quantities of
consciousness
[Music]
oh thanks
um yes sorry i forgot we were doing
clusters and i was thinking about
something else
um
[Music]
thanks very much uh so first of all i i
don't know about anyone else's room i
have a lot of questions for iat theory
which i don't think it's better director
sonia so i won't do that we can talk
about it another time or you can tell me
what to read
um
so i found these two papers really
provocative together and particularly i
was thinking about non-representational
theories right which have become
massively important in the social
sciences in general and i was thinking
about how
lee and jake's paper show us the kind of
critical value of using a
non-representational theory of
humans or personhood we could call it
some kind of like a subjectivity concept
or something
where you're looking at the way
different subjects are kind of
inaugurated or instantiated through
different kinds of discursive regimes
and there's a great critical you know
you're showing the great critical
potential of
uh working that way
um
and it occurred to me that something
what you showed was this sort of
productive tension between those
and that's a great methodology it
occurred to me that regulatory theory
might be completely fine with that so
we're all hearing that as a really
critical observation
but mainstream regulatory theory would
just say yeah
that's right that's what's happening
there's a rate there's a set of regimes
and they're working together to engineer
a certain
social goal so i wonder to you guys i
wonder if that's something you'd thought
about or worry about in terms of like
your intellectual apparatus and like how
do you then get a critical how do you
entrench that critical thing i know
jake's thinking about this um
anyway but anyway then occurred to me
like in so newspaper that a similar
kind of problem is going on but at a
completely different level it's two
registers that work together in that
discourse it's you've got a
non-representational register which is
this informational quantitative register
and it strikes me that's so weird to use
that as an argument to say let's now
have a representational construction
personhood is
intimately historically politically
representational and it will never not
be
um so
why then use this sort of
non-representational theory
to say and now the payout of that is we
get personhood which is a
representational apparatus and it
occurred it occurred to me maybe we've
got a similar we need to scale up our
zoom out
of the kinds of discourse that are
working together in these scenarios to
include the representational ones
where we that's where these sort of
power structures are really kind of
perhaps built in this nuclear command
and control game in other words
we can't do out do yet without this kind
of rhetorical
visibility game of personhood and
representation
jamaica first okay uh so
so peter i agree that it would be a
really good idea to look at the
different qualities of consciousness but
then at the same time with the nuclear
command and control in the way
swiss gable and pettit would list that
they've taken this argument
the way that they open the door to
normalize
that we could use this integrated
information theory they're they're
almost
they're trying to do some kind of an
imminent critique but i think they end
up justifying a paradigm and then the
question well i was just trying to show
where that paradigm would end up and
that it
i mean it's interesting to think i'm
going to parallel this now to the
representational because i hadn't really
thought of that but yes iit would not be
a representational notion of personhood
but i think that the way that more and
more we think about what is the
difference between a.i and a human
intelligence and more and more the way
that at least some of these some people
would just collapse and say no we're all
informational processing units like say
tech take max um tegmark for example so
that at that point um
there is a real question about well how
do you explain the agency of this actor
is it really that different if it's ia
artificial intelligence or human
intelligence and so then we just end up
in this world where maybe we can explain
all that we it's not explainable at some
level so it is easy to go to the
non-representational
uh analyses of how can you define the
levels of consciousness um for my own
work i guess the the first thing i'm
interested in a very basic level is
can is it fair to say that if you took
nuclear command and control and you
applied iit to it
would we have to conclude that it would
be a very intensely highly organized
systemic form of information processing
i think we would and i i don't know who
would be the ultimate decider of that
and then the question would be well what
would be the implications of it one
would be the materiality has this causal
trajectory of its own what are the tools
that we would need to seriously say this
is not the this world will self-destruct
within a certain amount of time
we need to bring meaning back and we
need to bring these qualities of
consciousness that peter
we need to bring those back so
so yeah so my first question is is my
analysis sound and then how can i use
that to perform some kind of imminent
critique of that approach but really
enjoyed both of your questions thank you
those are great questions and i'd
probably have to think about the more to
have like a good answer to i mean i i
really like where you're going with that
question i think i agree i mean we're
not necessarily trying to stake out a
position in the paper on what humans are
or are not but like to take the quality
of rationality which is the one that was
really at stake in our paper i totally
agree that it is a contingent phenomenon
that is architected through a set of
environments and not like a natural
endowment but the law treats it that way
in lots of cases and uses that idea of
it as a natural endowment to justify a
set of quasi-market situations where
this other ontological formulation of
rationality is something that can be
tuned and modulated and that emerges
from the context of the environment um
is allowed to exist and so like we we do
refer a little bit in the paper to like
work from science and technology studies
and economic sociology like michelle
colon who says like yes a rational
economic actor exists but not by nature
by way of market devices um so like i
totally think that's the case and yet i
don't think the the regulatory paradigms
are honest about that in some ways
um i mean behavioral economics starts to
acknowledge that yes like the
information environment has some impact
on the way that people process and make
choices but i think it still starts from
the presupposition of like that the
rationalities in some ways like an
endowment that's different from that
um
what's that
we're out of time but i could we maybe
um smith and fabian had questions can we
maybe at least get them on the table and
then that concede conversation in our
capacious three times sorry
okay
yeah sure um this is a question for lee
and jake so i really liked your
conception of the two-faced consumer and
as you were talking i was trying to
think of other examples of this
um
where
basically the human is being sold and
they are
the conceptualization of the human is
different to different stakeholders like
one example i can think of is in dating
apps but it's
slightly different in that you know like
to most users you're getting sold very
like western ideal of like you are
choosing your partner this is all about
you it's your individual choice but then
on the other hand the platform turns
around and like sells these premium
features like boost your profile and so
on that you know are obviously arranging
things so there's like still this choice
thing but the justification for choice
is like not quite a rational one but
like we have this judgment that's beyond
yeah so i'm just curious if you've
thought about like other contexts where
there's a similar contradiction comes up
and maybe through different values
these are great questions
yeah i was too late as well i'm sorry
about that but um my question would have
been for for sonia and i'm i'm dying to
read the paper um and to talk a little
bit um to take up a constitution about
uh iit but not in this context probably
um but i want to ask about the let's say
ideological implications of your project
because the idea reminded me a little
bit of uh you know bruno latour
actor network theory and the critiques
of that their network theory which
basically say they eliminate uh you know
specific concrete political positions
and dynamics so my question would have
been
you know what is at stake
in try even trying this what is at stake
in trying to explain or to apply iit to
command and control and related systems
so who's been benefiting from such a
perspective um at the end of the day
what are the ideological implications or
what is a potential ideological agenda
you know behind combining these two
specific things
thank you
okay that was an amazing session but
we're gonna break for lunch now and
you know these questions can hopefully
exceed good conversation over lunch and
over the next few days
[Music]
just imagine we have lunch there's still
plenty we were assembling correctly from
wrong fellow organizers
um two o'clock
right oh yep
so there's a good amount of time
you're on your own there is the faculty
club uh that's kind of a quick walk um
and relatively inexpensive relatively
inexpensive and um
but of course you have time to explore
berkeley what berkeley offers
um and
two o'clock shop and brilliant panel
thank you so much and salome brilliant